scenes like these from China cities in
lockdown becoming now familiar across
the globe following new deaths caused by
the novel coronavirus Asia remains the
continent hardest hit by the outbreak on
Sunday South Korea raised its deceased
alert level to the highest possible
there are hundreds of registered cases
in the country and the number of new
infections is still surging concern is
there a lot of people infected now but I
think there would not be so many
infections if people took better care of
the individual hygiene kept themselves
updated with the news or official
announcements and stayed away from
crowded places
meanwhile the covett 19 commonly known
as the corona virus is becoming
increasingly political in Iran's supreme
leader Ayatollah Ali Khamenei accused
Iran's enemies of spreading propaganda
about the virus online in order to
stifle voting in Saturday's
parliamentary election from you know
need hey you know how massively they
worked using various platforms to lower
voter turnout how do you know being in
hiding the last pretext they resorted to
was this corona virus which has scared
many you know do belong to who
however Iranians accused their
leadership of hiding the real scope of
the outbreak we don't know what's true
and what's false since the government is
constantly lying to us health experts
say maintaining a healthy immune system
is key to fighting off the virus
protective masks are now the dominant
picture of residents on alert in the
Philippines this wedding reception even
required attendees to wear facial
protection as the global coronavirus
outbreak still needs to be contained
taking care of one's personal hygiene
has for some become the ultimate
expression of
authorities in Italy have imposed a
travel ban on about a dozen towns in the
north of the country an effort to
prevent the spread of the corona virus
to people in Italy infected with the
virus have died and officials there are
reporting about another 80 confirmed
cases some 50,000 people are affected by
the lockdown which is near the city of
Milan the small town of cadonia
is at the epicenter of the outbreak
there the streets of cadonia were empty
on Saturday evening people in a dozen
towns in northern Italy were told to
stay indoors after a local woman died
presumably from the corona virus genome
posea Madeira SATA fat
we still can't say whether she died of
the corona virus or whether she had the
corona virus and died from other causes
because no autopsy or other tests have
been performed yet said what's your
officials confirmed the number of
infected persons in the Lombardy region
is growing I mean most I can say is that
the number of people infected in our
region has risen to 39 masks sold out
said these signs at a pharmacy in the
center of Code ownio earlier on Saturday
the town's train station was also eerily
empty hospitals in the region have been
taking strong precautions in nearby
Cremona health workers set up a first
aid unit in front of the hospital for
people who arrived believing they may be
infected as fears grow towns like
cadonia look set to remain largely
deserted until the virus is brought
under control more I'm joined by
virologist mountain stoma in Frankfurt
professor stoma thanks for joining me it
seems that the source of the outbreak in
Italy is still unclear why is that yeah
the possible person the contact person
has been in China of course but this
person
tested negative for the virus and the
person claimed that he had no symptoms
at all so this might sit more unlikely
that this is a contact person however
there's one possible explanation it
depends on when the meeting between
these two persons here was maybe some
days ago and maybe at this time the
person still was positive for the virus
and recovered in the meantime and that
it's the only explanation I have up to
now to explain this cluster right
Italian authorities are taking some
serious precautionary measures to
control and to contain this outbreak are
they making the right decision there
they they do the best they can they try
to avoid person-to-person contact as
much as possible and they try to avoid
people traveling into this region and
traveling outside this region so they do
the best they can Archer Lee and Chinese
authorities are reporting that the
incubation period which was originally
thought to be two weeks could actually
be a lot longer how likely is that it's
a single case it was a 70 years old man
and he had 27 days no symptoms but
positive virus
tests so although it's a single case
that it shows us that it might be even
more complicated to get the virus under
control yeah one of the latest countries
to be affected by the outbreak is Iran
with 20 28 and confirmed cases at the
moment and six deaths how serious is the
situation there yeah you think it's
serious because if you calculate the
numbers of deaths compared to the
numbers of infected people they report
for me it seems that we have more people
infected without knowing that actually
so it's serious area with the exception
of Egypt Africa hasn't been yet affected
by the outbreak but the World Health
Organization has warned that African
health systems aren't well-equipped
enough to cope with a potential outbreak
what needs to be done there yeah it's
it's the best way is to spend as much
efforts and as much money as we can to
prepare them for for being for for
having the why
in their countries however I'm not sure
whether it's possible and we hope
hopefully the virus will not come to
Africa monster Mart's reporting for us
from Frankfurt thank you